I hear that you always have you must
love singing you always have karaoke at
your parties well I didn't used to have
karaoke at my parties until I met my
wife she so she's better she a karaoke
genius a genius at it it's amazing
what's a go-to song for either one of
you uh well she she sings Karen
Carpenter like like Karen Carpenter
couldn't I mean it's amazing it's clear
as a valve yeah she's here she's up
there oh my gosh I love Karen Carpenter
it's amazing yeah when when she sings
those songs I can take all the madness
of the world has to give my God it's
just it's extraordinary it's so clear
and she also sings Desperado like no
one's ever I just sing Desperado here
ma'am it's about the sexiest thing
you've ever heard in your life when she
says you know open the gate like yeah
than like fine I will I love it coming
on in wait what's your go to uh I I tend
to sing uh I'll do Let's Dance by David
Bowie and uh we have another distinction
that I share with David Bo which is very
interesting I I had a little heart
trouble about uh 15 years ago yeah and
what the nurses told me was said oh
David Bowie was in his bed before
you you're like I'm gonna make it
finally finally have arrived that's
amazing and then and the guy and before
him was Paul Newman so like are you
serious they're probably not supposed to
tell you but that particular does this
person only work on super famous people
I think it was that it was that room
apparently so oh my
[Music]
gosh
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home